lo que vamos a hacer es escribir la
fracción 16 21 nuevos como un número
decimal y para eso lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es recordar que cuando
tenemos una fracción esta fracción es
exactamente igual al resultado que nos
da dividido 16 entre 21 ahora claramente
el 16 es más chico que el 21 entonces no
nos va a dar un número entero así es que
de una vez ponga mos el punto decimal y
algunos ceros a la derecha del punto
decimal ok
cuántas veces cabe el 21 en el 16 cabe 0
veces y ahora lo que vamos a ver es
cuántas veces cabe el 21 en el 160 ok
queremos poner aquí un número que sea el
número más grande que multiplicado por
21 nos queda algo más chico que 160 así
es que si nos fijamos nada más en el 16
y en el 2 osea quitamos estos dos
números podríamos decir que el 2 cabe
ocho veces en el 16 pero este uno va a
aportar más cosas
multiplicación entonces vamos a ver si 7
es suficientemente chico como para que 7
por 21 sea menor que 160 y además el
número más grande que podamos poner aquí
que entonces 7 por 17 7 por 2 14 y lo
que tenemos que hacer es restar esto y
para restar pues aquí este 6 le va a
pasar un 1 para que a este 0 se va a
convertir en un 10 y estos 6 se va a
convertir en un 5 entonces 10 menos 7
son 35 menos 4 son 11 menos 10 entonces
el 7 está muy bien ahí porque 147 si es
menor que 160 y además el recibo que nos
queda o sea el 13 es menor que 21
entonces este es el número más grande
que puede estar aquí ahora como tenemos
un residuo distinto de 0 pues tenemos
que seguir dividiendo entonces tenemos
que bajar otro 0 y bueno no sabemos si
este proceso de dividir y tener que
bajar 0
a ser infinito podría ser perfectamente
infinito porque hay decimales que tienen
una infinidad de números aquí pero
obviamente no tenemos que hacer todo eso
en caso de que esta fracción sea un
decimal con una cantidad infinita de
números por acá lo que vamos a hacer es
escoger cuatro décimas y redondear hacia
la tercera décima para que nos quede
redondeado hasta las milésimas por keith
por el momento ya bajamos el cero
entonces queremos dividir 130 entre 21
cuantas veces creen que va a caber eso
fuiste aquí ya no va a ser 7 porque si
pusiéramos un 7 nos quedaría 147 que es
definitivamente mayor que 130 pero que
les parece el 6 esto se hace un poco
jugando con los números y viendo cuál es
el mejor número aunque hay aquí otra vez
pues podemos dejar de ver estos dos
cifras y ver que pues el 6 queda muy
bien para que 2 por 6 nos quede algo que
es menor que 13 y además deje un poco de
unidades para que también lo podamos
sumar la multiplicación de 6 por 1 pero
a ver ya hagamos
y en las cuentas 6 x 1
6 x 2 12 y entonces tenemos que restar
esto por acá aquí este 3 le va a prestar
una decena a estas unidades para que
esto se convierta en un 10 entonces éste
se convierte en un 2 y entonces 10 menos
6 nos queda 4 y luego 2 menos 20 y 1
menos 10 que si es suficientemente
pequeño como para que estemos seguros de
que el número más grande que puede estar
aquí es el 6 entonces como el residuo no
es 0 vamos a bajar otro 0
ahora vamos a calcular el lugar de las
milésimas y pues aquí podemos ver que
aunque 2 x 12 4 no va a dejar espacio no
va a dejar unidades para el 2 x 1 de
aquí entonces el 2 es un número muy
grande para poner aquí entonces vamos a
tratar con el 1 y entonces 1 por 21 21
40 menos 21 19
ok 19 no es 0 entonces pues aquí va a ir
otro décimo y queremos redondear a las
milésimas pero estos tres decimales no
son suficientes para redondear a las
milésimas necesitamos otro número por
acá para poder redondear las milésimas
entonces vamos a agregar otro cero y
bajarlo hasta acá y cuántas veces creen
ustedes que quepa el 21 dentro de 190
pues 2 por 9 18 suena prometedor vamos a
probarlo 9 por 19 9 por 2 18 y restando
pues aquí solo sobra un 1
sí porque 189 más uno son 190 está muy
chiquito este número no pero no es
suficientemente pequeño como para decir
que 16 21 bosh es exactamente igual a
0.7619 para decir que si son iguales
este residuo tiene que ser exactamente
igual a 0 y bueno aquí claro
y dividiendo y quien sabe tal vez
después de 2008 a la derecha llegamos a
un residuo cero igual y nada más
necesitamos otros dos ceros pero por el
momento lo vamos a redondear a las
milésimas este número lo que tenemos que
hacer es preguntarnos si es mayor o
igual o si es menor que 5 pero resulta
que éste es mayor o igual que 5 y
entonces esto lo vamos a redondear hacia
arriba y entonces estas milésimas nos
van a quedar como un 2
así es que 16 21 nuevos se redondea a un
decimal 0.76 2